soy un dragón un dragón de lavapiés
cuando tenía 6 años hace ya 4 mi padre y
yo hacíamos listas de los amigos del
barrio que me gustaría tener en un
equipo de futuro imaginario los dragones
de fuego después cuando pusiéramos un
cartel se apuntaron muchos más
moha sant roc y violeta adiós a olga
en poco tiempo y vamos a ser más de 100
empezamos a entrenar duro en las canchas
del casino de la reina pero para ser un
equipo de verdad
necesitábamos equipaciones y como no
teníamos mucho dinero
nos enteramos de que había una ng que la
regalaba su presidente era un diputado
catalán
el señor maldonado y nuestras primeras
equipaciones fuimos a buscarlas al
congreso de diputados con los carritos
de la compra
los leones creo calcinaban pero
alucinaron aún más los niños del parque
cuando abrimos las cajas y aparecieron
guantes medias pantalones camisetas
apuntamos a cinco equipos a la liga
municipal al hacer las fichas nos dimos
cuenta de que habían niños de todos los
puntos del planeta
marruecos senegal bangladesh república
dominicana taiwán nuestros entrenadores
también eran de muchos países
emiliano en méxico pavo de gambia luis y
andrés de ecuador y raúl de perú nos
parecía todo muy bonito pero nada más
empezar la temporada insultaron en el
campo a moha un niño que juega muy bien
al fútbol por su color de piel
monja tenía entonces nueve años y tenía
cara de no saber dónde se había metido
en ese lío
hasta tuvimos que llamar a la policía
pero esto no se quedó aquí la siguiente
temporada un árbitro cambió el resultado
diciendo que habíamos empatado cuando
habíamos ganado es a mí nos pareció muy
raro y esa misma noche en facebook
descubrimos que tenía ideología racista
le sancionaron pero nunca nos llegó a
pedir disculpas y claro nos dimos cuenta
de que había que hacer algo para luchar
contra el racismo
que hicimos un torneo colaborando con el
movimiento contra el racismo y la
intolerancia también hicimos durante dos
años un programa de radio la cueva del
dragón
pero faltaban
nos preguntamos que le preocupa más a la
gente de todo el mundo sólo se nos
ocurría una cosa el fútbol
menos mal que la 1 tenía una lista una
lista con 17 objetivos de desarrollo
sostenible los dos los jóvenes son un
plan mundial para luchar por la paz y la
justicia en todo el mundo por los
estudios de calidad por no alambre por
no a la pobreza
también hicimos un torneo de los 17 los
goles porque darnos a conocer marca la
dirección hacia donde debemos de caminar
a los torneos que vamos y si conocemos a
gente importante les regalamos estos
balones con los 17 goles impresos y
hechos en kenia
los niños pueden ayudar a cumplir los 17
goles empezando por su bar
el nuestro es lavapiés acabando por todo
el mundo todos podemos marcar un gol
hasta yo que soy portero muchas gracias
[Aplausos]